hey we're on hey happy Father's Day yeah
I called my dad yeah how you doing I
don't know you talked to him a long time
yeah okay no can't you part house yeah
yeah yeah that's it yeah that's pretty
much what he sounds like yeah all right
hey Weez just one doctor after another
once you get to a certain age that's
pretty much what it is I think we just
have like one person waiting but you
know whatever people will drop by
alright so something you know sidetracks
yesterday we thought we would do a
matinee today so this is kind of like a
little bit of a different thing but this
is kind of a cool thing that shutter did
this year so there's this film festival
called the atheria Film Festival it's
been going since 2014 and it's basically
like a festival of horror sigh short
films directed by women they usually
have it at the Egyptian Theatre in
Hollywood you know they usually have a
big party and panel discussions and
stuff like that but obviously this year
they couldn't do that so what they
decided to do was basically have the
festival completely online so they
partnered with shutter and shutter
basically put up all nine of these
shorts that were selected like in one
just big long thing that you can watch
and then they had just like an
introduction and I think they're gonna
do like some panel discussions and stuff
like that now I don't think it's staying
up on shutter it's only up there for
like a short period of time I came a
when up on the 19th and then it's gonna
stay up until like the 27th or something
that's staying up for like a week so
people can watch it but I thought that
was kind of like a cool thing to do like
as a compromise because they couldn't
have people there in person so now this
is a collection of nine shorts and like
I said they show them like just one
after the other they don't like have
anything in between or anything and it
ends up being about I think it was two
hours and eight minutes long
so you can just I just kind of sat down
and like watched all of them in a row
have to say like all of these were good
like good great you know what I mean
it's like you know obviously you're
gonna like some of them better than
others just because that's people's
personal tastes and stuff but I mean
pretty much every one of these was
pretty entertaining and it's like that
if there was a lot of different um
different genre type films like
represented a couple of them were kind
of like more like black mirror episodes
like sci-fi some of them were like
funnier some of them were you know more
straight-up horror some so it was a good
flick there was only one time I didn't
like and that was the one where all the
trans people tied up the preacher type
of deal and then they cuz there wasn't
any twist in it okay yeah that was one
twisted it wasn't it wasn't a twist I
was expecting I thought watching it I
was like how much I bet he's a willing
participant that's what I thought that's
how it was gonna go dad yeah that it was
a big fetish thing but then it was just
not kind of like a straight revenge
flick kind of reminded me of the very
first one very first story in that
Twilight zones movie series the guy just
gets shut it off oh yeah yeah they kind
of liked that it was gonna like that you
know where it was just kind of like a
straightforward we hate you and get the
[ __ ] out of here movie and I thought it
was weak you know and I mean they could
have done a but much better twist at the
end yeah like I said there was kind of a
twist but not exactly the one winds
though but yes so I get it's weird
because I was like there's not really a
lot of reviews on this I sounded like
one guy that had like a really really
small channel and he had reviewed it and
I think the one that he picked is his
favorite maybe that's my favorite too
but it's actually kind of like hard to
pick cuz like I said a lot of them were
really good and they were kind of like
all over the place like you know
somatically and stuff so it was like
kind of hard to choose which ones and a
couple of them were like really funny
like horror comedies and stuff which I
thought was like really well pulled off
but so let's kind of go through and you
know we'll talk about the ones that are
that we're on there the first one that
they show is called waffle now this was
11 minutes long and it was directed by
Carlin Hudson now this was kind of like
a dark comedy
this one had a little bit of a black
mirror kind of vibe because the whole
setup was that there's this woman named
Katie who is a waffle heiress hence the
name waffle and she's like clearly very
socially awkward and kind of like
emotionally stunted because she kind of
like even though she's clearly like in
her you know late 20s or early 30s she
still kind of acts like a teenager and
has like kind of kid like pajamas and
she wants to have a sleepover and stuff
and so you open like on this sleepover
type situation which is kind of awkward
and you're not really sure why at first
but then you figure out that this is
kind of like either it's a little bit in
the future it's a little bit of an
alternate future where there's kind of
like an app where you can essentially
like pay for a best friend like somebody
to hang out with you and like be your
best friend and do what you want to do
so that's kind of how that ends up going
I really did like like the interaction
between these two women and like the one
the waffle heiress lady who's like
clearly and not and then the other woman
who's just like she's just like hey my
times up you need to put more money in
and [ __ ] like that you know what I mean
and then the woman like getting madder
and madder and like obsessed and stuff
so this one was like pretty entertaining
mostly funny um I don't think I don't
remember this one being like uber uber
gory but it was kind of like more a dark
comedy but it was kind of like a door
elements to I mean I just thought it was
okay yeah and also had a little bit of a
twist at the end which I liked I didn't
think was that strange because they got
[ __ ] like that in Japan now that's what
I mean so I guess it's not really that
futuristic because it was essentially
just like calling you know an uber or
like grub or something like that except
a friend right what you're right they do
have an edge if they had that kind of
thing friends for hi where you can like
rent friends Yeah right people hang out
they call it an English teacher teachers
a [ __ ] metaphor for that are
euphemism for that oh that's pretty
funny yeah it's usually a white guy and
a [ __ ] Japanese girl she hires an
English teacher you're her friend an
English teacher yeah yeah it's not it's
a bit of both yeah
it's they just want somebody to hang out
with they want some yeah interaction
right and they tell the husband he's
just my teacher yeah yeah I see how that
works out yeah he's gone to the [ __ ]
hostess club well yeah that's what I
mean it's good you know Hey
yeah you can't like she's she's she's
allowed to have her fun too right I
could make a lot of money doing that
with your back you're a [ __ ]
millionaire yeah you should have gone
over there like back when your head
you're like you know you talk back when
I had all my charms yeah way back then
yeah way back when you had back when I
had all my charms girl and [ __ ] I was
just gonna say you worked it though it
didn't look it you know everybody had
that everybody that day so it's kind of
like you know it looks ridiculous on
some people we didn't know any better it
looks nice on you and he didn't know
when you could pull it off yeah
megabases my dad did that yeah now the
second one which is the one that the
other reviewer picked at their favorite
eye I liked this one this one was
probably the most messed up on this was
an Australian one directed by Mia Kate
Russell this one was 14 minutes long
this is probably like the most straight
up horror when I'm like I said it was
kind of the most [ __ ] up in terms of
like the thematic the subject matter
kind of a set up of it was there was a
funeral
apparently the matriarch of this family
had died and there were several sisters
I believe at least two of them were
sisters I think the third woman was a
sister too but I couldn't tell if it was
a sister just like a friend to one of
the sisters it didn't really matter
and essentially what ends up happening
is that the one sister who's like this
big this big gigantic woman with kind of
like a mustache and she had like these
ridiculous I'm they made her look like
as grotesque as I've ever seen if you
ever seen the lab remember that Bluto
ludo I'm like a mouth and everything
yeah they made her look like as horrible
as possible like just like a grotesque
like yeah like a John Waters type
character type of things used piece of
[ __ ] yeah and so the whole thing was
that her I think the whole theme of this
was that sometimes like doing nothing is
like you know worse than doing like a
bad thing because this her character is
just literally so apathetic yeah that
she will just like sit there on the TV
like eating Cheetos like watching the
tube while literally like horrible
horrible [ __ ] is happening yeah meaning
around her the whole meaning of her life
is I didn't do anything yeah I didn't do
anything but that's kind of what that's
like that's the her mortal sin you
didn't do it yeah do anything because
this one and this one like I said
probably had the best like practical
effects because I don't really want to
spoil what happens to the other sister
in this one and the fact that you know
the big horribly grotesque like couch
potato sister doesn't do anything to
help um but it's pretty gross yeah it
gets worse than that and it definitely
gets worse than that this was definitely
the most fucked-up one and like I said
the other reviewer I saw he said he
picked this one as his favor because it
was the most I think this was the most
straightforward horror that it wasn't
funny it was like a Twilight Zone oh it
was yeah kind of like that except much
much grosser and more modern kind of
more [ __ ] up so um I don't know if I
might pick this one as my favorite - I
mean I liked a lot of them but this one
was like really good just cuz it was
really messed up like I said it was
Australian the third one this one was
kind of amusing this was called basic
which which I thought was very funny
was there a pumpkin spice latte in this
indeed there was I didn't see any yoga
pants though but you know that's
can't-miss trick directed by yoko
umemura and it was 12 minutes long more
of a fantasy than a horror and kind of
like comedic this one was kind of
something to do so the woman who's like
the main character her name is Lily and
they kind of showed that she's a witch
at the beginning it's very like you know
which of the vswir type of thing where
she's making the candles come on and
everything and
she has um had a night of passion with
this dude I don't know if she had known
him previously if they'd been dating for
a while if it was a one-night stand or
something like that it wasn't real clear
on that but it didn't really make a huge
amount of difference you could tell that
they kind of knew each other but not
super well and um I guess he had had
like a super good time with the sex and
her not so much so she puts a spell on
him so that he can experience everything
that she experienced during the night
have like all the thoughts and emotions
that she had and stuff like that and it
is delightfully funny he turned him into
a woman well he well she made him made
him feel like what she felt and thought
like during the whole situation which I
thought was it was very funny and it was
it's not like I mean I just thought it
was like really really funny the way it
was done like especially when he goes
off like at the end like after that
because he has like all the physical
sensations - yeah which is arrested - so
hilarious she'd want to play my game but
that's my game - um yes and everybody
knows women aren't as good it's just
different
but the hilarious was an orange the
thing that made me laugh the hardest
other than all I'm gonna say is surprise
but stuff but um that made me laugh
really hard but also when like after the
end like after all the physical stuff
was done like when he was kind of
channeling like what like all of the
things that she was thinking like all
the conflicting emotions and he was like
saying all this stuff and I was like wow
they nailed that it's like really hard
because I'd had like the exact same like
process like it he was like saying it
out loud and it just like maybe laughing
I don't have that well like I said
that's why well that's why you could
tell this is joy because it's like
that's exactly I'm like that's that's
exactly what a woman would think that's
like how you would think that's how you
would feel it's like that's exactly
right so it's like but see that was the
whole point of the short was that dudes
don't understand that right right um and
so the fact that she kind of put his
hand into her she called it yeah and
it's like that was kind of the whole
point but it was done like in a really
funny like light-hearted kind of way was
it heavy-handed it wasn't like because
it was just very it was just um
really light touch and I thought that it
was like really really I mean it was a
it was an okay yeah it wasn't poor
necessary but like I said this you know
the whole point of this Film Festival is
horror sci-fi and fantasy so I guess I'd
put this more than the fantasy thing all
ghosts yeah I guess it's more it's not
like black mirror because it wasn't
technology based it was like you know
because she was a witch and she was like
putting his balance Australian one was
the best one yeah now that I'm thinking
like the more I think about it that was
the one that I think affected me the
most just because it was so messed up
and like I said it just goes to it just
goes to show like how you know apathy
can be like the worst thing of all Rama
Sesana live-action it's not animated
it's all live-action yeah there were a
little movies yeah they're good quality
I don't know like cuz like I said this
has been going for 2014 and I went to
the website and they had like all the
shorts from the previous years but I
didn't notice if any of them were
animated I'm sure I imagine that if you
did an animated one they would probably
do it because I guess they have like um
you know kind of famous judges like
injury because I guess a lot of people
submit films and then they only picked
the best ones I know that Gale Anne Hurd
who was one of the show runners on
Walking Dead was was on the jury in
silicon Avadh salon said that they
needed to do a tusks remake they just
made that enough as it is you guys
haven't seen tusk it's a divisive movie
like I just gotta see that again
I liked it actually like I said Kevin
Smith's disturbing oh yeah it was
actually it it was well and the nice
thing about tusk and I think we
mentioned this before was that we went
into it not knowing anything about yeah
I didn't know what it was gonna be about
all I knew was that a friend of ours
Shana who was on you know one of our
like past shows yeah she just recommend
she's like just watch it she's like it's
so [ __ ] up and we didn't know anything
and that it Kevin Smith that directed it
so yeah that's all we know so the next
short was the one you were talking about
earlier which is called the conversion
therapist that was directed by bears
Rebecca fonte
20 minutes long and this is one where
there was a I guess he's like a preacher
and he's looking at runs one of those
pray the gay away camps and so a
reowww like basically kidnaps and
tortures them and tries to get into like
change his ways and stuff like that
pretty straightforward like I said it
might have been a little bit better if
it had had it did have kind of a twisted
thing but not this wasn't good a big
enough twist because yeah like you said
you said oh they should make the twist
this that right because I was caught and
I said I know this is gonna go yeah this
is it didn't go quite like that I
thought it was gonna be a paid for
service and that this was just like a
sexual fantasy because there was a lot
of sexual [ __ ] that happened did it true
yeah that and it would have may have
been a much better if if he was in yeah
what if like that cuz they go okay you
know because there's like yeah that
makes total sense the best game the best
prey the gay away movie we saw was that
was very good that web movie that we saw
at AMC remember that about the kid who
goes to the pretty gay away camp oh yeah
it was a good [ __ ] movie epidemic oh
I remember you not liking it always on
no I liked it oh I liked it the name of
it I thought it's pretty good I got out
I got out now goes that was a trip and
then and then it gave updates on all the
characters yeah and all the prey the gay
way people turned out to they all they
were all gay yeah they're all good
that's what I always say it's to like me
just it's okay just yeah just there a
church someone pray the gay away
services yeah and then it turns out
oh no they all came out of the closet
they were all guards it was just kind of
like every single time like and this is
going back to as far as I can remember
when I was a kid in the 70s and 80s
every time you see one of these [ __ ]
televangelist and stuff like that going
on and on about we had this one that was
in Florida I like that about you going
on about porn yeah and it's like then
they they died or something like that
this huge stash like they have a huge
thing before it's like if they it's a
projection that's what I mean if they
weren't so [ __ ] worried about it you
didn't worry about other people on it
the only time you ever gonna find some
religious person constantly [ __ ]
stressing out over gay people dudes gay
that's what I mean because why else
would they care what other people are
doing that don't have doesn't have
anything you straight religious people
don't even think about it they don't
care about that's what I mean it's like
why he asked me like I said why would
you even go hey it's nothing to do with
any it's nothing to do with you I would
it be on their mind all the time why
would they be worried about it they're
trying to get it out of themselves
exactly I don't worry about what other
people what other people are doing in
there why would I worry about
but yeah okay so the next one this one
was from the Netherlands so it was in
Dutch this was the only one that was not
English language this one was this one
in the last one were probably most like
a black mayor episode this was called
offbeat and it was 20 minutes long and
apparently they don't you know it's
mostly just implied which I thought was
was good but there's just like a brief
scene at the beginning where it's
sometime in the future
the air quality outside is just too
completely gone to [ __ ] and so people
can't live outside without masks and
various other things and so I guess
there's a place like a kind of um you
know an Eden sort of place where it's
like a dome and you can go in there
where there's fresh oxygen and stuff but
they but you have to go through this
series of tests before they'll let you
live in the dome so you're basically
following this guy named Ali and he
really badly wants to get into the dome
because he's kind of like a punk rocker
kind of dude he's gonna leather jacket
and he wants to be a drummer and he must
be the like the best drummer in the
world yeah and he's got he's a Middle
Eastern heritage too yeah which the [ __ ]
it kind of comes into play yes so they
go through so it's him and like I think
it's four other contenders and they're
trying to go through this series of
weird tests like to be able to be
allowed to live in the dome so they have
to go through like they have to do like
a Rorschach type of test and you have to
do like [ __ ] with what's up for you for
your reflexes and all this other stuff
and it's funny because this one's
actually kind of funny because yeah you
know he'll like say certain things it's
like the wrong s they're like oh you are
depressed and you are a homo and all
this other stuff like just goes through
its Regan point so it's kind of like a
post-apocalyptic Logan's Run he's trying
to get into the dumb yeah yeah that'd be
a good way to describe it this is one of
the better episodes I did like this
video it's not horror though no like I
said this is more but like I said there
yeah it's it's sci-fi um it's it's
definitely like a black mirror type
episode I like that and it reminded me
of it actually reminded me of that black
mayor episode I can't remember a title
of it but the one with the Dallas Bryce
Howard in it or
where everyone was social media and they
do right everybody I yeah it was kind of
like that a little bit just like on a
little bit of a smaller scale I guess
but like I said it's a short film it's
only 20 minutes long but you know these
are all good so it's kind of hard for me
to like pick one of the other because
and they're really different one of the
things you may you know earlier and some
of the earlier episodes I talked about I
said the movies of the future actually
gonna be better movies targeted without
you know I mean they're not gonna be
real long and they're not gonna have
[ __ ] celebrities in them and they're
gonna have a lot more impact this is
what I was talking about yeah you know
and and what was the one with the damn
sci-fi one that we saw blood machines
yeah there's gonna be a lot of stuff
like that now well like I said that's
gonna be the winning we're going back to
the age of the auteur I guess where
you're just gonna get like one or two
persons vision making a damn cool
[ __ ] figures you can make a cool
flick for not that much money and you
can get it seen by a lot of people yeah
I haven't seen blood machines go see
blood machine yeah that is also on
shudder yeah it's on shudder it's not
it's not a movie it's well it's a movie
but it's a series like a series but it's
only three episodes yeah and it adds up
to being about like a movie yeah it's a
it's an hour long an hour long and it's
but imagine imagine if a movie was also
a music video in a way yeah it has
elements of that in it I just thought I
I could just like watch it I thought it
was genius I thought it was kind of like
the rebirth of [ __ ] Star Wars yeah
where it's kind of like a [ __ ]
low-budget but really good sci-fi
fantasy
yes movie and it's and it's freewheeling
you don't know what the hell is going
like I said that's kind of why I like
and that's one of the things that I like
about shudder and like I said we don't
get like you know any sponsorship money
or nothing like that I just really like
shudder you know life listen we've had
it for a long time and I like that they
seem particularly you know they have a
lot of old movies and they try to get
new ones and stuff but they really seem
to be committed to bringing you bringing
you indie movies and like and stuff like
this which i think is really cool
because like I said this festival which
has been going for several years and
they couldn't do the theater thing that
they usually do so shudder was like hey
we'll put them on our platform and so
maybe more people would see them I mean
because now anybody that has shudder can
watch them instead of you know having to
go to the theater like you would have
before and all I went to see there and
we you know June I had that AMC and AMC
was fun to get out of the house we saw a
lot of movies for how long was that
about a year and a half yeah something
like that a year and a half and it was
only 20 bucks a month and there were
some good movies that we saw it
definitely they sure but you know I'm
[ __ ] just shut her alone gave it a run
for its money Colorado space your head
[ __ ] man we rented color out of a
rented that one yeah but we don't see
that in AMC no they didn't play it nope
um you know the [ __ ] that we saw like on
blood machines which that was that was
actually a shudder you said it was a
shudder yeah I just think you know the
streaming services are [ __ ]
competitive with well yeah with what now
that they are making their own stuff too
and I'm not saying that like every
single indie movie or every single you
know original movie that shuttered is
brilliant no um you know some of them
are better than others right but I just
like I mean I would rather watch
something like that an independent
filmmaker made that wasn't all that
great then watch something that was like
you know cost thirty billion dollar
members of varium yeah that we saw
Bavaria Mon what but we rented that I
rented that on Xbox
I loved that yeah that was a good movie
and I loved that
I don't think AMC would have shown that
they showed it in some cities but not
here not here told you yeah and we've
had that problem in Florida a lot it's
like it really does seem like I don't
know it's like they'll show stuff in
like New York and LA and stuff like that
but or big cities but looking back over
that year and a half the best movie I
saw out of AMC that wasn't like a
tentpole movie was the artist
self-defense
yeah that was the best one out of that
year and that ended up being streaming
to or you could get that an xbox but
it's just it was man Hollywood and am si
was hit and miss big-time big-time and
like I said a lot of it's the the
location to because I mean that's been
going back I mean cuz I remember when I
was a kid and Brahms a teenager and we
would always complain because I was
really into like independent movies
horror movies you know weird movies and
we always bitched because it's like it
would play like in theaters and
in actual cities but where I grew up in
theirs and a beach that would never play
it was always like the real popular
stuff and that was it you couldn't see
any movie the best times we had at AMC I
would say aside from tentpole movies was
when they live streamed the the rupture
of trash out and then when they really
in ones that was a good the Channing and
the shiny yeah that's pretty good
I like yeah I liked being able to see I
mean old movies they should have been
playing older old movies and we didn't
have a blast at this room yes yes really
good I hope in a way it's like I would
be sad in theaters didn't come back just
because of that because I like being
able to go and see it with other fans
and stuff well if Ames she comes back
I'm sure they'll have that they said
that they were reopening that well they
were talking about reopening some of it
in July but I'm not sure if they're
going to or not like so they're closing
some of the locations that weren't
profitable but ours was one of the
bigger locations but you know what F
[ __ ] was you're mostly dead during the
day dude yeah although to be fair we
never went like at prime times we for
that reason we always went like in the
middle of the day like because we knew
it wouldn't be as crowded because I
don't like sitting like [ __ ] people
people are gross but yeah alright so um
let's see so the next one which is kind
of more this one was the most like a
slasher movie but it was also kind of
like a deconstruction of a slasher movie
if that makes any sense this was called
the final girl returns
Mandy Nicole says her high directed by
Alexandria Perez and this one was 16
minutes long now this one was kind of
weird because it was kind of like it was
it was essentially like a cabin in the
woods slasher but it was like meta or it
was like it was like an endless loop of
this guy who apparently had escaped from
a slasher and then he was in this card
it was almost like he was doomed to keep
coming back to this same place in the
road and like rescuing like all the
subsequent final girls that came out of
the situation and it's almost kind of
like they were saying that it was almost
kind of like a simulation I guess
because you know when they would tell
the cops that cops wouldn't believe them
the cops would go back to the cabin and
there's nothing there because they would
say oh that's all these people are dead
and all this other kind of stuff
so it was kind of like an endless loop
of like slasher movie guns and then it
had to get resolved like in a certain
way and Connor Watts Ron said he didn't
get but the ending of the varium the
ending of ovarium the secret to it is
the beginning of the varium the woman
finds birds on the ground they had been
kicked out of the nest by a cuckoo bird
yeah all right that's what they had
encountered some kind of extra
dimensional cuckoo bird it made you
raise its children yeah and then it
killed you and then the child went out
and back to the office to get the next
couple to get em to raise the the child
it seemed to be from another dimension
some kind of an F yeah it was an
interdimensional and a dimensional alien
of some sort and that's what was making
you raise that software making you raise
its offspring it was [ __ ] creepy but I
brilliant I kind of spoiled the movie
but you guys should see vivere him it's
pretty good I liked it it's just we're
just yeah it creeps me out
which like I said it helps because I had
seen a trailer for it but I had kind of
you know but the trailers good at like
just giving off a really creepy vibe but
it didn't really tell you what what
exactly was gonna happen in it so I like
that I like approaching as an alien
parasite yeah I think that's because
like I said it's the whole Cooper thing
we've seen we've seen you know the
predator an Alien Hunter this is an
alien parasite yeah and this is how it
would come get you yeah some weird [ __ ]
somebody recommended life-changer I bet
somebody else recommended that to me and
I still haven't got around to watching
it yet I think that is on it's either on
shudder in Netflix because I remember
seeing it like when I scroll through
there I'm gonna have to watch that one
of these days because you're like the
second or third person that's
recommended that's Mesa yeah I do
definitely okay so the next short was
called live this one was directed by
Taryn O'Neill who also starred in it
this one was 12 minutes long this one
was again a little bit like a black
mayor episode in the sense that it was
maybe set a little bit in the future but
it's about this woman who basically
livestreams she has like an underground
Fight Club where she fights
other chicks and so she livestreams it
and it's kind of like making like I said
not horror more sci-fi but it's kind of
making a statement about how everyone's
lives have gone completely online and
you can't even have a life outside of
that anymore because she's always on
like you know whether it's in the Fight
Club or whether it's like we can kind of
relate to it yeah even though I don't
know no not really because I have like a
whole bunch of most of writing books
yeah and me just research you're
watching [ __ ] and then thinking about
riding a motorcycle I haven't [ __ ]
been riding my motorcycle about what a
year I thought you went I want to come
take a couple weeks back but or not a
week or two I used to write every
[ __ ] day you did yeah I remember
yeah because sometimes like when I used
to when I used to actually have to like
commute to work and stuff like that
sometimes I would like drop like on the
way home from work I'd drop by and like
hang out at Starbucks yeah right up
there with Starbucks and hang out with
your friends as though age is a hell of
a drug like I said every sometime yeah
but yeah so so that one like I said more
like a black mirror episode where it's
just kind of like you know technology
taking over people's lives so they can't
have a life outside of you know them
just being on all the time
live-streaming and you know her fighting
with her boyfriend about maybe she
should go into porn or maybe they should
do this the other thing so then the next
one was called man in the corner I think
this is a shortest one because it was
only about nine minutes long this one
was actually kind of funny because it's
basically like two dudes and you know
they're hooking out there I'm this big
like hot and heavy thing and then all of
a sudden there's this creepy old dude
like standing in the corner of the room
it's like the one guy who's come over
it's just kind of like um that's
probably a red flag who's that weird old
oh that's just Dave and then like as it
goes on like I said this was pretty
short it was a really weird one and then
like you find out at the end like what
Dave was maybe or you know I didn't
really understand it yeah it was - home
arrived for me I kept looking away and
there was like a man there was like a
lot of
okay so if you're in the lasix if you're
in a gay porn then this is the way for
young girls would love it yeah it's it
yeah this was a directed by Kelly
Breslin if I didn't say I'm like I said
this one was only about 9 minutes long I
think that's a shortest one but yeah so
the he's creepy fat ol guy but yeah like
lots of Nikki that was creepy those two
dudes have sex and the old do watch
trying to get in bed with a [ __ ]
who's that yeah it was like kind of
creepy all right and then the last time
she goes to first I thought it goes it
wasn't quite that but it was yeah it was
kind of sure what to make of it
yeah it was it was a little ambiguous I
think I know what they're saying but
yeah so then the last one which actually
I really likes this one a lot this is
probably like the most like a black
mayor episode but this one was kind of
sci-fi but it was also kind of funny
this was called Ava in the end and it
was directed by Ursula Ellis now this
one I'm a woman wakes up and she's in
the cloud cuz apparently she's died and
she died in the stupidest way possible
like tripping over her dog and like
hitting her head on a coffee table so
she's in the cloud and her only other
companion is this computer kind of
serious see ya like a Siri type figure
who tells her that she's dead and it's
like this is like the waiting area
before you get a new body and everything
like that and it's just the interaction
between because it's basically just said
in this one like weird room where
there's like no you know it's just kind
of like weird 80s looking triangles and
technological stuff and everything so
it's just like the interaction between
this kind of [ __ ]
computer and this [ __ ] girl named Ava
it's like one of the funniest things
that it was when she was I guess she was
like putting on Twitter or something
like that she's like died in a really
[ __ ] stupid way and this computer is
like giving me [ __ ] or something and
it's just like hashtag [ __ ] computer or
something yeah it's like so she's like a
total Karen about a conviction about the
service like in the cloud and everything
and then like as it goes on it's funny
because it builds up as being like
really really funny like a comedy but
there's like a revelation like partway
through it ever it's only ten minutes
there's a revelation partway through it
that makes it actually kind of sad and
like actually kind of poignant I'm not
gonna spoil it um but you find out
something like really bad it's gonna
maybe it's not gonna work out the way
she thinks and it's so it's actually
kind of sad at the end but um this one I
think this one and Maggie Mae the one
with the woman that didn't want to do
anything the apathetic woman like I
didn't do anything
um I think these two were probably my
favorite ones kind of hard I liked
waffle two the first one just because I
loved that crazy girl like she was such
in that case like with her [ __ ]
pajamas and everything I didn't like
this from that much you didn't like this
on that one job because it was too much
of a hopeless situation so she couldn't
find a way out of it or anything like
that you know I mean there there had to
been I thought I thought there had to
been a way where she could have saved
herself to have a deal but you know I
mean you spoil it but well yeah that's
what I mean there forgot it was like I
mean well the thing is it's like you
know the situation was resolved it just
wasn't resolved in a way that was to
anyone's benefit I guess we'll just put
it I forgot which ones came out this
that was that that was the last one yeah
like I said there was just nine short
they were all worth seeing yeah and it's
like I said there wasn't like a crappy
one in the whole like there were none of
them cuz sometimes you know you see an
anthology movie or something you know
this isn't exactly like that because
these were all separate but some overall
I'd probably give it to the one where
the guy was trying to get into the dome
I think I like that one the best
that was a really good one too like I
said it's hard to pick because it's like
it was all in German I think when uh
Dutch Dutch yeah it was it was made in
another one or so yeah that one was the
only one that wasn't because even though
there was really didn't matter though
yeah it didn't I mean you know and even
though some of the directors were not
American because I think one of them was
directed by Japanese woman and like
there were a couple other ones but all
of them were in English except for that
one and that was in Dutch so you know
like I said if you're into [ __ ] horns
I find you want to see some cool short
films you know by independent filmmakers
female filmmakers that make horror and
sci-fi and all that kind of stuff
then what that's another cool name for
it
yeah that's another cool name for a
shirt it's homoerotic and it's too much
for me yes yes I have to say that if any
of if anyone is uncomfortable with
seeing two dudes having sex then
probably yeah skip that one
yeah I'm not bothered I think it's got
sixteen people in here let me stand
flashbulbs juicy juicy [ __ ] airplane
where the dudes the dudes are coming off
[ __ ] plane oh thank you thank you
[Laughter]
there you go
that's some flashbulbs because a [ __ ]
huge flash that's my story and that's a
flash in the comics
oh he says for the drinks fund in a
fantastic witching hour this week thank
you that's I'm glad some people are
enjoying those it's like I'm kind of
like I actually finished reading all the
stories for my hopeful monsters book
today so I only have I have three more
stories to edit they're all recorded so
I'm gonna put the print and the eBook
version up like the second edition like
this is a book the the first edition
came out in 2009 but I added like three
or four or five stories to it and then
like I'm doing an audio because I never
did an audiobook version of any of my
fiction before so I'm kind of trying to
get around to doing that so I did finish
recording it today I just got to edit a
few more and then I'll get it put up so
probably be a couple weeks for it
arrives yeah it takes a really long time
alright so are we done talking about the
moon yes you guys got any questions any
guys want to talk about anything uh any
ideas for any upcoming shows Sanders
says sounds like it's time for Tom's old
man nap yeah
[Laughter]
that sounds like a good yeah I was
thinking it was man it's Sunday I might
have a [ __ ] Bloody Mary or something
yeah I gotta use up the rest that zing
Zang it's taking up all that space in
the fridge that's my excuse somebody for
the fridge problem yeah if you guys have
the scene um the art of self-defense you
guys need to rent that you can rent that
off an Xbox or probably Amazon you can
probably run on YouTube but surely if
you can rent it on Xbox
I've noticed you can pretty much rent it
pretty much anywhere that's what you
know you know you know you guys know I'm
into [ __ ] martial arts and [ __ ]
laughing at martial arts and that's the
truth about what it's I well the thing
that I dug about that movie with it and
it's funny because like I said when we
were watching it in the theater because
we saw it in the theater um I thought
that you were not gonna like it because
usually that's my kind of thing like
that really really dry you know uh like
very subtle like humor you know what I
mean it was painful at first because the
main character is so [ __ ] but that's
what he was supposed to be like yeah he
had to be that way to this [ __ ] come
Foucault and then once it started
unfolding I was like man this is true
I'm like yeah this is this is basically
they're talking about count Dante I mean
the ones the one scene where he goes in
and just like punches his boss in the
face yeah and then he just like goes in
the [ __ ] break room I punched the boss
in the face it felt awesome
in his sensei's telling him to get more
macho that he had to start listening to
metal and that he had to get rid of his
wiener dog macho [ __ ] and then it was
funny you know
man he's bullying the dudes at the
office that he works with or tried I
said he did bully there he said I did
bully them it's just dorky dude bullying
him around and [ __ ] you guys gotta see
it man it's good movie really good I
thought it was acting it was kind of
making fun of that over-the-top manly
man type of like where he wasn't even
like allowed to do things that he liked
any
yeah it wasn't manly and it's just like
that was just like really funny to me
yeah but that was no that made sense to
me
yeah that actually made sense to me well
what was funny was how in the end the
honor of the dojo was restored yeah so
it wasn't really like an anti kung-fu or
anti no it was just that it had been
provided perverted by a dude who is
selfish and cheating and [ __ ] didn't
have any damn Honorables our honor yeah
and he was making money illegally in
illegal ways to [ __ ] support the dojo
and he wasn't he wasn't training he was
providing his own customers by [ __ ]
beating people up that was another weird
thing yeah it's just it's a very twisted
a very twisted situation of how that
dojo operated yeah and people who left
the dojo still had to pay for
memberships because he had so much dirt
on there was all kinds of [ __ ] weird
[ __ ] and it was so and all that [ __ ]
actually has happened in those dojo
yeah it's just that it was all happening
in one dojo in this story it was getting
on like count Dante and then a bunch of
other weird [ __ ] happening the Black
Dragon Society is like that so what's it
like darker yeah it was like exaggerated
but not that much not that much you know
it kind of brought back my days of my
[ __ ] step brother Billy and [ __ ]
and [ __ ] ninja gym and all the
[ __ ] stupid things yeah ninja gym
ninja gym was basically that guy who was
the main character in an [ __ ] gym was a
little bit tougher yeah yeah yeah not
much he was like a wannabe cop you know
but you know he would never really make
it as a cop yeah he ended up I think
being an EMT but that's not what he
wanted to be yeah he wanted to be a cop
and a [ __ ] ninja he wanted to be
Chuck Norris that's what he wanted to be
this is back in like eighties no one has
no one has
Chester to be he wanted to be Chuck
Norris from the up from the optics from
the Octagon and he wanted to be Chuck
Norris from missing-in-action he wanted
to be all and he wanted to be mad max
wanted to be everything yeah okay yeah
Sanders said the last scene of art of
self-defense made the movie perfect yeah
kind of perfect I really did love that
last I've laughed so [ __ ] hard like
in the theater I don't usually like to
do that because it's you know worried
other people watching it but it's like I
just like [ __ ] cracked up at that
last second scene alright so we're gonna
wrap up this hold on people asses what
you seen the lighthouse yes we saw a lot
yes it was pretty good Ally I really
liked it I thought it was like super
weird and I like I said I'm all for
people making just [ __ ] weird-ass
movies like that it's like don't even
just let your freak flag fly man like
don't even give a [ __ ] if people don't
like it or not just make what you want
to make okay if it's weird
and there's a movie called Iceman from
two-seven
it's like the revenant very good movie
okay
spoke in an ancient language we can
understand the story visually this kind
of probably kind of like quest for fire
that sounds kind of cool actually talk
about the last scene of our self-defense
uh some of my list to see this week
tonight I would be watching a series one
a creek show okay okay yeah yeah we need
Chuck Norris or the next next Mad Max
film I hope the next Mad Max film was
good it should be really good I mean
based on it'd be hard to top the last
one but if they won't sure my well he
probably could top that yeah well he
probably could we probably would it
would have to be different
of course yeah but that's kind of what
all the Mad Max movies were all wrong
with each other right know what I mean
which I kind of liked I'm sure that I'm
sure he could do some it was somatically
the same but they would tell a different
story time which I thought was kind of
cool like in a way I'm like furiosa
isn't in it I think furiosa should be a
spin-off movie she needs her own movie
yes she's rad as hell I mean they they
need to do like a whole thing with that
yeah I would watch that yeah he's got to
get the right he said that he has the
right people to pick up the right the
rains after him if he goes if he dies he
better not die
George Miller yeah I think the next Mad
Max kind of has to be a darker movie
more boot toned and more blue maybe
something happened mostly at night
someone like that yeah that'd be called
if I do use it because I think it
visually has to look different and you
see the desert can get kind of
monotonous maybe something underground I
don't know
difficult to say what if there was a
whole underground society driving around
and [ __ ] underground [ __ ] roads
and stuff oh my god get away that just
reminded me of that [ __ ] movie that I
was just watching on Mystery Science
Theater the other day was Kathy Ireland
in it underground Australians okay I
didn't see it Oh alien from LA yeah yeah
I think I think I remember that was
pretty bad how's the town yeah but what
if it was a huge scale yeah I mean that
can be done better roughly it has been
done better because I liked that idea
they just didn't do it I mean it was the
[ __ ] cannon Falmer under there under
the conditions have you seen that Mad
Max world be an underground might be
better
you might you'd be able to keep water
there might be underwater yeah on the
water I think yeah that'd be good
actually and then you hollow it all out
and then there's like there's still cars
and [ __ ] but they're underground yeah
and they're pumping oil underneath there
and everything kind of like maybe in
like at a huge abandoned salt mine
something like that yeah see that would
kick ass yeah yeah that would probably
make more sense yeah senator said I
finally watched Mad Max fury road I'm
absolutely not into action movies and I
loved it yeah I know and like it's a
mess we saw it well when it was in the
theaters we saw it six times yeah um we
saw it in 3d we thought not in 3d was I
look [ __ ] we saw it like every
different format have you seen the road
warrior if you haven't seen the road
warrior you've got to see the road
warrior yeah I mean the thing about Mad
Max fury road I remember the first time
we went and saw it in the theater it's
like you felt like because seeing it in
the theater it's like really big we were
like in the front first or second row
it's like we felt like we would beat up
by awesomeness it was just like you're
just braining awesomeness down on me the
whole time I was just like tired at the
end of it but like in a good way
Oh Jason Voorhees from the third part is
a copy of humongous of Mad Max another
thing about nothing about Lord humungus
from
um road warrior is that some stuff got
cut out of the story originally the idea
was is that max was gonna find out that
Lord humungus was actually the goose
because remember his friend Jim goose
got burned up but I never died okay
so what was gonna happen he's gonna find
out the humongous was the goose and then
the goose was gonna try to convince max
to join him to join him on the dark side
yeah
and man I wish they would have left that
in there but they decided to take it out
because they thought that the [ __ ]
American market and it had a bigger
budget and they knew it would probably
sell real well in the American market
they thought that people from the
American market hadn't seen the first
one right so they wouldn't know who
goose who this well so it wouldn't have
the same impact right yeah which is a
shame cuz man it it makes so much more
sense when you see road warrior and the
things that who you mungus was doing and
saying it makes a lot more sense when
you when you take an account that it's
supposed to be the goose yeah you know
oh well but I don't know if you guys
knew that what are you gonna do yeah
Kent so you got a do [ __ ] for American
on it yes and it's like you know and
people it's a it's kind of like always
it's it always makes me laugh too
because it fills you when you see like
you know like European or British horror
movies and a lot of times they have to
do like a happy ending like for America
because like for some reason American
audiences don't like downbeat endings or
depressing endings where everyone dies
or anything so it's always like we have
to have one person survive we have to
have this in the other because I think
most famously like the dissent which has
like a really a bummer ending it had a
different ending for the American one
where I guess did she get away at the
end I've only seen like a UK version
because I'm not watching that happy I
think [ __ ] like that alright so uh
you done talking yeah I'm down to almost
go ahead and just couldn't close it down
alright so we'll probably do another
live stream tomorrow either another
movie review or another side tracks if
we watch something new tonight we'll
review it yeah wish you guys mark and so
we'll see you guys Farah have a good
rest of your weekend
all right